hello everyone this game came as a
suggestion from a subscriber and it's
definitely quite a game it was played in
September
it's the 2017 Isle of Man tournament by
chess calm the game was played between
vajrasana Cobian and alexandra Lenderman
both of them American chess grandmasters
even though Alko bian was born in
Armenia and Lenderman in Leningrad but
there's a very young age they moved to
the United States and they are now today
American chess grandmasters and it's I
mean it's round eight you you definitely
want to scrub up some more points but
you don't want to lose the game and
that's what makes this game extremely
interesting it's like each of the
players didn't really care about what
the other guy was doing they were just
going on with their own plan that's how
I see this game and it's really at one
point aqua bein really tries to achieve
a brilliancy and bring home a whole
point but in the end
well you'll just see what happens so ah
Cobian has the white pieces and he plays
d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6 nice the
c3 and the Bishop to b4 the nimzo-indian
defense and it seems like in the last
couple of videos there are a lot of
names of Indians Queen to c2 the classic
variations I remember in the previous
videos I uploaded we had some a3 ideas
III ideas Knight to f3 ideas but here
Queen to c2 was played a Lenderman
castles now a3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and d5 still we're in the
classical variation Knight to f3 D
captures on c4 Queen captures on c4 and
b6 as this knight on f6 is now
protecting d5 and d4 when this Bishop
comes to b7 the these two pieces will be
complementing each other very nicely and
this is a beautiful diagonal for this
Bishop and here already an interesting
move by aqua beyond h4
so what's the idea here the idea is he
wants to he wants to mix it up Bishop to
a6 now kicking the Queen away from c4
Queen to c2 and we have
when to d5 what ideas of maybe Bishop
coming back to b7 to pressure this G to
pawn as white already pushed H for
another thing the the black queen is
doing it seems like she's stopping the
move h5 and you don't want to play a
move like g3 here because you already
played h4 so this would be a pretty weak
structure at the guard your king and the
playing a move like III allows Bishop
captures on an f1 also not not maybe the
best thing for white but white doesn't
matter
he plays h5 you know it seems like black
didn't stop this by playing Queen to d5
and one other thing by playing Queen to
d5 black offered white this c7 pawn but
if white captures this after Knight to
c6 and Queen to f4 94 black has too much
activity for this pawn you don't want to
allow a strong Grandmaster to have the
this kind of activity for the price of
only one point so after Queen to d5 h5
was played by aqua bian and here we have
again an interesting variation why can't
the knight capture this h5 pawn well if
the knight captures you get E 4 and the
problem is black is losing the knight
the Queen has nowhere to go if you try
and move like Queen to a5 this is even
worse you get before and now you're
losing the Queen instead of the night so
after this h5 move Lenderman played rook
to c8 we have h6 now and with with this
cheeky moves it seems that occupy
managed to push h4 h5 and h6 in a row so
this is a quite an achievement black is
now forced to weaken the King structure
he has to push g6 and weaken the dark
squares b4 Knight to e4 and we have rook
to h4 a nice rook lift now with a double
attack on the Knight f5 a Lenderman
isn't afraid of anything coming his way
Knight to g5 he would enjoy exchanging
the strong knight on e4 but Lenderman
decides
to do this Knight to d6 and already he
played a couple of moves with this night
this is not something you want to do
when you have an undeveloped night and
b6 a rockin beat I'm sorry I'm on b8
orokin a8 and the rockin c8 Bishop to f4
and what's the idea here
can black capture this pawn on d4 I mean
sure he can but after Queen characters
on d4 the queen is getting in line of
this rockin H for this is not something
you want to do and for example after
rook the c1 how do you develop here with
black you can't really develop your
knight Knight the square c6 is not
available if you try something like
Knight to d7 you get III the Queen has
to move and after the Queen moves Queen
f6 you lose the bishop on a6 so again
this would be too much activity for
white for the price of a pawn
so after Bishop to f4 Bishop to c4 was
played now black has ideas of quinta b5
to pressure the e2 pawn
we have f3 White is preparing to push e4
Knight to d7 now black is able to
develop the Knight e4 and this is well
almost the critical moment of the game
white is giving black a couple of
options do you want to play F captures I
need 4 or do we want to play Queen
captures on b4 like I said this is
around 8 and both players are eager to
muster up some more points in before the
tournament ends and playing a move like
F captures on e4 with result in Bishop
captures on c4 Knight captures Queen
captures on e4 probably the exchange of
Queens and well with equal material
black has to get his hooks into the game
but probably this is a an easy draw for
for grandmasters like aqua Beyond and
Lenderman so after E for Lenderman
decided to play Queen captures on d4 and
this is where the fun begins the queen
is not threatening to come to g1 and
this looks really impressive as this
would pressure this Bishop on f1 since
it's already attacked from the bishop on
c4
but it seems
fabien doesn't care about this rook to
d1 Bayaka beyond Lenderman of course
plays Queen to g1 now threatening Queen
captures on f1 and now we've reached the
critical moment of the game here there
are a lot of moves that are you know
possible that come to mind but in round
eight of the Isle of Man tournament
probably in time trouble I haven't seen
this game live I Coogan decided to go
for the for the fantasy Queen captures
on c4 sacrificing the Queen and now
there is no more threat of Queen
captures on f1 and other than capturing
the queen with the night there really
isn't a good move
so Knight captures Queen and c4 and the
rook captures night on d7 Lenderman
immediately plays Knight to e3 now
threatening to capture the bishop with
Queen captures on f1 and here we have
rook to g7 with check the problem is you
can't get rid of this night on e3 if
Bishop captures and III and Queen
captures after Bishop to e2 blocking the
check you lose the night on g5 black is
up simply too much material so after
Knight to h3 rope the g7 check kink to
f8 and now Knight captures and h7 was
played King to d8 Knight to f6 and now
of course not came to be a this would
result in a rock to d7 checkmate
but instead King back to f8 Knight to d7
check King to d7 King to d8 Knight to f6
King f8 97 Qingyi a Knight of 6 and it's
a threefold repetition the players
agreed to a draw no player can make
progress one thing that might have led
Akopian to sacrifice the Queen which
Queen captures on c4 was that in this
position after Knight checked on d7 and
King t8 maybe he thought that he had a
win with h7
the problem is with this move maybe he
thought that okay Queen captures an f1
maybe I can get out of the checks but
the problem is this losses by force
after Queen captures would check now
King Teddy to Queen to f2 with check the
Knight is guarding the C 2 square
if king to c1 or king to c3 Queen to c2
wins the game by easily checkmating the
white king so King had to go to d3 and
if F captures on e4 would check F
captures on e4 now Queen to c2 check
forcing the King either to go up the
board which leads to checkmate so he
would have to capture the night Queen to
c3 with the check and now after the King
moves Queen captures rook on g7 and
white is simply out of options if he
promotes the pawn to Queen Queen
captures no problem rook captures and
King captures night on d7 and being the
exchange up and the pawn up this would
have been easily easily winning by by
oxana Lenderman
so none of this happened after Knight to
f6 players agree to a draw and that's it
for this story or is it we should go
back to the position before occupy and
bravely decided to sacrifice his queen
let's see this move Queen to g1 was
played so Linderman is threatening to
capture the bishop on f1 and like I said
this is definitely the critical moment
of the game Queen captures on c4 was a
brave decision akka beyond saw that he
will get the bishop people captured the
97 he will grab this h7 pawn with the
night and probably will be able to push
h7 and h8 the victory but unfortunately
later he probably sought this variation
that leads to two black winning the game
so in this position instead of capturing
Queen captures on c4 Whitehead the very
elegant rook the d3 move and well simply
winning the game what's the idea here
the idea is now that the rook is in v3
you're blocking Queen captures on f1 and
you're threatening Bishop to e3 and if
the bishop comes to e3 the black queen
is trapped so but it has to do something
about this probably the worst thing you
could do here is capture the rook with
the bishop if Bishop captures Queen
captures again life achieve nothing he
still can't get the Queen out there
Bishop Bishop to e3 is still a great
threat and after for example F captures
to attack the White Queen Knight
captures now we have Knight captures and
now a Queen captures knight on e4 black
is black is in a lot of trouble Queen
captures on e6 is a threat and after you
stop this with rook to e8 you get Bishop
to e3 the Queen is trapped and it's game
over Knight to f6 unfortunately it
doesn't work because of Queen to e5
black queen is still attacked and you
can't go back with Knight to d7 because
you get the Queen to g7 with checkmate
so this is one way to go so I have to
rip to d3
capturing with the bishop unfortunately
doesn't work although this required a
lot of calculation the best defense here
would be F captures on e4
because now Bishop to e3 doesn't work
Black has this resource of playing Queen
captures on f1 with Czech temporarily
sacrificing the Queen and after King
captures and now Bishop captures winning
back the Queen Queen captures he
captures on d3
and well Mike is simply much better here
up a piece that d3 pawn is already so
far ahead so let's just look at one more
option after rook to d3 we said that F
captures on e4 was the best move for
black but now not Bishop to e3
definitely but the best move here is
Queen to c3 and now black is completely
lost with this Queen to c3 move white
gains a brutal tempo and that is Queen
to g7 checkmate and now like simply
doesn't have a response to this he has
to stop this g5 and our Bishop to e3
wins the Queen black would have to play
Queen captures on f1 King captures and
after Bishop to d3 with Czech simply
King the g1 and black would have some
counter play here but with correct play
I believe occupy honor we have no
problem winning this position so yeah
unfortunately I have no idea White Queen
captures on c4 was played whether it was
thinking that D h-bond will win the game
or maybe it was time trouble he didn't
have time to calculate r up to d3 and
maybe he saw that Queen captures in c4
was a secure draw and the one for it
either way it's it's it's a shame that
this this rook to d3 brilliance it
wasn't played as it really creates
creates a very nice and complicated game
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon